despite the pandemic we're just months
away from the opening of resorts world
and with it the promise of thousands of
jobs
it's been in the work for years now just
south of sahara right near the
convention center drive area
resorts world began the hiring process
months ago interviewing
applicants virtually to focus on helping
bring las vegas back 400 people
currently employed
the goal now is to have 6 000 employees
in place
one month before the grand opening as
for a date they haven't nailed down an
exact date yet but say it won't be too
far in the future
we know we're going to open this summer
so it gives us a little lead way
we're watching what's going on with the
pandemic we're waiting to make sure
things get better
so again sometime this summer for sure
i'm thinking that could be great help
out more people to be able to get a job
because we're in tough times that we are
there's also a lot of construction
around as traffic lights walkways and
pipes are wired and built
resorts world says it is proud to be
able to help so many in the valley find
jobs
in what is really a tough time